I promise you [__] an album you've
been patiently waiting out a day is
finally present I took my time with this
[__] I put my mind into every line cuz
when inside I ain't trying to regret it
[__] get overhyped and all that hits
Ghost Rider taking you so long to put
out something because I feel like funk
volume has hit it's like hottest point
without you being so active yeah that's
good yeah yeah because it's almost like
you know you can set you up perfectly
yeah I don't the reason why I took so
long is point I'm a perfectionist
- I got into a relationship man I tell
you what your lady at I rock the bells I
think I saw you with a lady Oh No yeah
that was my home yeah that was my home
girl which one of us it was at the
center I saw you with the white chicken
oh yeah yeah homegirl yeah so be clear
yeah but last year I was in a
relationship I was in a relationship
that I got into a few years before that
but he just kind of [__] you up yeah
it just ain't up for one I was lost I
was like I didn't know it I don't know
what I wanted to grab but I've tried
poking my royal mount I didn't know what
I wanted to rap about do you know what I
wanted to talk about I was just I was
living off with the success I was
touring I was getting money so I want to
rap about that like yeah I've got this
made $20,000 on to [__] right overages I
don't want to do [__] like this on my
man I need some real life experiences
for me and I got a relationship that
slow me down because you know trying to
have more [__] taking time yeah and then
you know and as a human you want both
you like man I gotta kick it my girl
I gotta [__] be aware studio being
rather than anyway so I chose the girls
side yeah of course yeah it started this
wasn't really putting out music aside
from the old mines then I broke up with
my I broke up with my girl early earlier
this year his game the [__] spark and
now it's a wrap
yeah unfortunately it gave me stuff to
talk about on the album about good I
feel like you know I feel like I feel
like heartbreak Bruce is the best music
and you know it does well not bad I make
the best [__] songs you could ever
hear dope and I hate that because it's
gonna hurt her feelings but hey man I
mean think of like all the flat back to
Eminem think about the classic chemistry
yeah I don't know I know
you know you get those two sides as a
rapper you want to be the dopest
[__] you want to put everybody
on glass I'm gonna be really you like
then you also gotta be in you're like
man she's only human I can't hurt her
like that you know how is that gonna do
to her whether she wants to commit
suicide wish what if that mrs. Marber so
in this like man you gotta find that
balance and then it almost like you
almost kind of came to the point to
where you kind of do you uh you know
like we talked about you kind of
switched up your mentality when he
claimed when it comes to there maybe
some of the concert yeah yeah yeah I
went through the whole five I was
putting out you know what you talking
about yeah I'll come out from where like
you started talking more about like like
you know like in a lot of you're gonna
be some opposition yeah last year I got
I got baptized and with my
and we became strong Christians was she
up was she a big influences no I was it
feels very okay yeah so I was something
I wanted to do tonight talked her into
it but then I broke up with her before a
little bit before that I went on the
tour manager and [__] my head up doing
it's hard to torch this lifestyle was so
sinister dysfunction in up I got to her
and I was like I don't know who I am
anymore I don't know what I believe in I
don't know what are you I started making
my own little sense of things like wait
maybe this is that maybe there maybe God
doesn't do this I mean I just lost
everything and all the sudden it was
just and they not trading my locker in
the cellar
all right now I'm really excited to hear
now that I've made nine minutes it is
raw I'm not gonna lie it is raw it
sounds like a top-notch underground
album cause they explain good it doesn't
sound commercial at all it just sounds
like top-notch underground so you can
hear it and you'll be able to tell these
guys underground yeah it's not we would
I mean that's what I'm a [__] hit my
pan into the core so that's the kind of
[__] I want to hear I got this one song
called hip hop sinister hip hop sinister
what was on almost everybody phone call
you okay yeah
it's really wrong man it's just this
simple roster out of the beats is simple
we're just he's speaking and this
concepts a lot of deep songs with it
he's the [__] horrible whap trapper
he's whack period no way around it he is
black in the dick in the dictionary
whack em enemies these to me he's the
best rapper of all time